Where you are right now doesn't have to determine where you'll end up.
No one's written your destiny for you...
...because here in America, you write your own destiny.
You make your own future.
That's what young people like you are doing every day, all across America.
Young people like Jazmin Perez, from Roma, Texas.
Jazmin didn't speak English when she first started school.
Neither of her parents had gone to college.
But she worked hard, earned good grades and got a scholarship to Brown University.
Now in graduate school, studying public health. On her way to becoming Dr. Jazmin Perez.
I'm thinking about Andoni Schultz, from Los Altos, California,...
...who's fought brain cancer since he was three.
He's had to endure all sorts of treatments and surgeries.
One of which affected his memory, so it took him much longer,...
...hundreds of extra hours, to do his schoolwork.
But he never fell behind.
He's headed to college this fall.
And then there's Shantell Steve, from my hometown of Chicago, Illinois.
Even when bouncing from foster home to foster home in the toughest neighborhoods in the city,...
...she managed to get a job at a local health care center,...
...start a program to keep young people out of gangs...
...and she's on track to graduate high school with honors, and go on to college.
And Jazmin, Andoni, and Shantell aren't any different from any of you.
They face challenges in their lives just like you do.
In some cases, they've got it a lot worse off than many of you.
But they refused to give up.
They chose to take responsibility for their lives,...
...for their education...
...and set goals for themselves.
And I expect all of you to do the same.